par marie-caroline le pen bonsoir sa
cabane minuit on a reçu beaucoup
d'hommes politiques que maintenant à
cause de la campagne présidentielle on
va en voir à peu près partout on l'a
décidé d'inviter les enfants des hommes
politiques donc vous inaugurez là vous
inaugurez la rubrique vous êtes rendu
compte à quel âge que vous étiez la
fille de jean marie le pen sur du court
et m'écoutais je m'en suis rendu compte
je vous dis exactement sur souviens bien
j'avais 11 ans on n'a pas du tout été
élevé dans une atmosphère de politique
on n'est pas politique à la maison et
jeté en j'étais au lycée camille sée que
tel c'est très bcbg de blouses roses et
j'étais en salle de cour d'appel en
permanence voilà et ont une jeune fille
qui vous faisait le jeu on était 40 50
je ne suis très très sopi tarder avec
des cheveux rouges et je suivais le pnds
vous la fidh si tristement célèbre le
pen je n'avais pas compris et à partir
de ce moment là j'ai cru comprendre
quelque chose de différent et me suis
intéressé à partir de ce moment là parce
que jusque là j'avais pas je savais pas
je n'ai pas fait attention mon père
était allé tvq tgv telle chose dont on
parle pas de ça à la maison donc ses
textes à l'école que j'ai surfé de ça a
commencé
est ce que vous avez pensé à ce moment
là souffert d'un certain ostracisme de
la part de vos camarades d'école
camarades d'école moins loin que
professeur je le dis bon professeur
puisque les camarades d'école on nous a
pas cheap on ne l'est pas donc je mets
souffert de de ce côté là mais du côté
des professeurs ni vous pensez que vous
mettez des moins bonnes notes son côté
est ce que vous étiez là la fille de
jean marie le guen c'est plus qu'une
pensée parce que ça quand vous a quand
même bien d'hermès d'autres sujets que
j'ai mérité au canon on est c'était
c'était sur les notes c'était sur des
petits détails qui sont qui sont qui
sont pas très très important après coup
mik
si vous voulez me le fait de se servir
de son nom de son statut de professeur
pour passer ses idées politiques ou pour
martyriser tous à oxo d'abord où l'on
trouve ça lamentable des rues jeunes
professeurs de gauche que le professeur
l'extrême droite quand même oui vous
savez oui je sais mais chez les belges
il était comment le pen comme père j'ai
quand vous étiez petit vivier droite
soir les boîtes
comment ça se passe et où est-ce qu'elle
était terrible à la maison nom n'était
pas terrible du tout je sais mes
camarades me demandait souvent mais ton
père doit de battre non pas du tout au
contraire ont pas été très gentils la
peur très gentil j'étais lupus a
vraiment de mes soeurs c'est noël je
suis l'aîné donc on la sort qu'à 18 ans
sortie en beauté fascinante mots mais je
ne remercie les sauts triple à 6 ans
quand vous avez votre premier jules
qu'est ce qu'il a dit rien rien mais les
bleus ne donne aux affaires gta cage au
premier vous voulez dire et on joue dur
au premier flot voire mieux fermer le
premier jeu le sérieux chez qu'ils
étaient allés passer une nuit au quai où
est située la maison pour faire ce genre
de confidences avant non est ce que vous
pensez comme jean marie le pen que les
camps de concentration c'est un détail
de l'histoire
cemex a été mal
mal interprété exploité d'une manière
lettres ans hier on ne va pas revenir
sur cette querelle et puis jouer il ya
une chose je suis préoccupé par les
totalitarismes présent et voir ce qu'il
va se passer pour mes enfants et mes
soeurs et c'est vraiment ce qui s'est
passé il ya 40 ans je crois que
enfin vous dénoncez pas quand je démonte
pas de quoi non pas faire une mise au
point
elle nous est pas qu il était faite
là-dessus critics cette phrase a été mal
interprétée et mise au point qui a été
fait donc on peut plus parler de ce qui
a été dit avant mais on peut
éventuellement parler de la mise au
point donc ça n'a duré seulement il sait
s'adapter absolument pas ça vous choque
pas tellement quoi qu'on en dise les
trucs comme ça
non ça ne me choque pas puisque ça a été
mal interprétés et avec moi j'entends
bien
enfin presque donc ça veut dire que tous
les gens qui étaient là en malentendus
non pas tous les gens qui étaient là une
journaliste qui ont rapporté la cheville
enfin c'était diffusé à la radio c'était
diffusé à la radio il souhaite exploiter
deux mais vous êtes quand même bien
placé pour savoir que d'une phrase on
peut exploiter une phrase d'une manière
différente mais pas du tout quand on
quand on parle des camps de
concentration à quelqu'un dit que c'est
un détail
je veux dire c'est les citoyens à
différentes interprétations existe un
point de détail de l'histoire dans le
sens on s'est eu une partie de
l'histoire de la guerre ça est expliqué
ce appuyons pas dire qu'ils mettaient en
doute l'existence des chambres à gaz
là ça a été fait seulement évidemment il
ya une mise au point qui a duré 20
minutes qui était extrêmement précise et
la dérision ans n'a passé que deux
autres les mini comme d'habitude si tout
et ça vous fait quand on accuse de votre
père d'être un peu nazis un peu
antisémite comme ça ça vous fait quoi
comme comme il fait vous qui le
connaissez ça fait rien pour moi je suis
blindé comme depuis depuis des
et puis je connais mon père je sais très
bien ce qu'il est donc ça m'attriste un
peu parce que je trouve ça un peu
ridicule je pense que les gens qui
disent n entre pas persuadé moi je pense
que ça fait partie du jeu médiatique
puisque si le pen n'est plus nazis et si
les plus racistes or il est trop bien
donc il faut et quand ils dénoncent des
journalistes et comme par hasard c'est
dé sortir tous les noms mais je veux
voir des trucs qui sortent et
l'argentine à des noms de journalistes
moi franchement moi perçue par jean
françois kahn y voit qu'il y avait des
gens daniel par exemple jean ganiayre
moi je sais pas qu'il était juif jetez
vous savez pas dit votre père non mais
écoutez moi je suis désolé vous savez
vous qui est juif qu'il peut jouer mais
je sais pas je n'avais donc c'est une
manière de savoir si on les quatre qu'il
a pris par hasard ils étaient juifs chez
pas en face et des trucs mais vous vous
saviez qui moi je ne savais pas qu'ils
étaient tous je suis désolé mais penser
que les danses les trous je n'en sais
rien il se trouve que ces quatre
personnes étaient des personnes qui
avaient pris parti dans une histoire qui
est l affaire de marquer il avait monté
en sauce d'une manière tout à fait et où
l'on table et donc il a été cité mais je
pense qu'il ya de là à penser que
c'était parce qu'ils étaient juifs aux
roues avant que l'esprit vraiment
spécial parce que je crois c'est que si
la antisémite pourquoi il ne dit pas je
ya des gens avant guerre qu'il le disait
c'était c'est un courant de pensée
française c'est que ce soit le seul
sujet de conversation qu'on puisse avoir
risqué une émission humoristique cécé
loua passait pas une émission
humoristique c'est une émission si l'on
en discute exemple il est quand même un
peu plus antisémite que chirac les eaux
où ben oui pourquoi vous savez ce que
montage on dit en privé ce qu'ils
pensent des imprimés j'en suis montée
d'arrivée je peux vous dire qu'il est
pas antisémite c'est tout bon jadis les
primes des parts de zain antisémites et
les parties ses mixes et passionnante
pour moi open n'est pas antisémite s'est
passé à l'autre c'est qu'ils sont quand
vous êtes catholique
je suis content et les pratiquantes
savait que le pape a dénoncé le racisme
vous ne ferez pas oui mon père est un
raciste rapaille et les vous la renvoyez
les les arabes et les noirs chez eux
c'est pas pratique c'est pas très
charitable c'est pas ça chrétiens
créatures plus nuancé que ça vous
expliquer tout avant la pression des
créations existence est pas renvoyer les
noirs et les arabes chez eux s'est
régularisée l'immigration qui est pas un
pro qui n'est pas un problème racial qui
d'après effectivement d'identité culture
dans le monde à venir
mais quitte à problèmes économiques mais
pourquoi toujours amené sa jetée jeter
un oeil noir et les arabes a rien à voir
je comprends pas si vous restez d'être
la fille d'un homme politique
non pas du tout pour rester pas d'être
la fille de jean-marie le pen certains
dont je suis très fier vous en êtes fier
à oui tout à fait c'est quoi votre
ambition politique c'est pas dans les
chapelles qui clouerait l'on prendrait
la suite non pourquoi faudrait il
faudrait bien quelqu'un là c'est
franchement pas le nom jour je prends
mon temps à peine dynastie un cépage et
avec votre mère alors il s'est passé
quoi laisser passer de telles choses qui
m'intéressent pour personne je pouvais
parler dont elle parle quand même
mais puisque vous
je repasse à grave quand même je sais
pas quand on est chrétien et charitable
que votre mère ait eu un amant ce qu'on
aime pas grave je veux dire non donc tu
franchement là je vous arrête je ne
parle pas c'est pas que c'est pas grave
il ya des millions de gens qu'on aime
est très soudé ah non je veux pas en
quoi ça vous choque
aucun rapport je pense que ma mère était
manipulé et je pense qu'effectivement
c'est très grave c'est très triste mais
j'ai pas envie d'en parler je pense que
ça va tu as connu pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de la latitude
abonnez vous il mettait un peu de bleu